es ist natürlich eine messlatte für
sprachsysteme die auch immer bestehen
bleiben wird und wo immer jemand den
ehrgeiz haben wird die zu knacken wer
trinkt es trotzdem noch bestanden wenn
ich jetzt sagen würde ich wir haben
jetzt irgendwie schwingt spd versucht zu
erkennen lenkt mich ab und schummelt
quasi es würde sehr menschliche
eigenschaft er soll den menschen wie ihn
gibt in dem film auch die stelle wo er
sagt sie kann nur so mit mir
interagieren reagieren wenn sie ein
bewusstsein gab es falsch wie kann das
auch
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wissenschaftler reagieren in kooperation
mit der max planck gesellschaft und wie
immer gilt das hier ist der erste teil
auf meinem kanal und den zweiten teil
gibt es dann auf dem kanal der
max-planck-gesellschaft das ganze hat
mir dann gleich im abspann verlinkt oder
auch um in der video beschreibung und
ich sitze hier neben doktor annika
buchholz du bist am max planck institut
für intelligente systeme in tübingen und
beschäftigt sich dort mit künstlicher
intelligenz jeden tag ich bin ein
wissenschaftsmanagement angesiedelt das
heißt arbeit an der schnittstelle von
forschung und management es geht
einerseits darum verschiedene bereiche
und verschiedene forschung miteinander
zu verknüpfen und andererseits bis jetzt
natürlich auch schon mal dass da ein
projekt mit rein rutschen und dann
konkrete fragestellung mit untersuchen
wir gucken heute ex machina ich weiß
nicht sagt dass jedes mal aber es ist
einer meiner lieblingsfilme glaub ich
habe das große glück dass mir
tatsächlich erlaubt wird jedes mal über
einen meiner lieblingsfilme im video zu
machen kam 2014 'raus bis zum jahr 2015
in deutschland habe ich dann auch im
kino gesehen von alex garland seien die
bücher ganz gut bevor jetzt zu sehr in
diesem film rein gehen wir werden
wahrscheinlich die ganze zeit das wort
kunst also christi fans sagen wir werden
wahrscheinlich aber auch maschinen
learning sagen wir werden algorithmus
sagen was bedeutet diese
begrifflichkeiten können sich
intelligenz erstmal ein riesiges gebiet
das sich damit beschäftigt das maschinen
oder wesentlich nicht mehr menschen sind
die israels verhalten aufweisen und
maschinelles lernen ist das was er im
forschungs contrexx gebraucht wird viele
formen der k arbeiten damit dass ein
algorithmus etwas lärmt algorithmus
selber ist dann auf die implementierung
auf den computer die umsetzung von der
idee die man hat so da hat er noch
wirklich will und vielleicht noch kann
man ein bisschen jetzt für diesen film
daneben auch stellen das feld der
robotik es gibt natürlich robotik die
mit kontrolle theorie arbeitet und nicht
wird künstliche intelligenz oder
maschinellem lernen und es gibt die
schnittstelle die ist natürlich jetzt
gerade interessant wir haben uns ein
paar spannende szenen rausgesucht und
ich bin schon sehr gespannt hast du dass
du sagen willst für euch achtung spoiler
wir werden uns jetzt alle szenen aus dem
film angucken wenn ihr ex knacki noch
nicht gesehen hat letzte chance es ist
auf jeden fall besser diese videos hier
gesehen zu haben wenn ihr gerade frisch
davor den kompletten film gesehen habt
also es geht weißt du was der touring
tastic
ja ich weiß was der theorie test ist das
ist ja auch ein experte die
programmierer es geht dabei um die
interaktion zwischen mensch und computer
wenn den menschen nicht auffällt dass
sein gegenüber ein computer ist geld der
test als bestanden und wenn er bestanden
ist was heißt das dass der computer
künstliche intelligenz aufweist
entwickelst du eine ki ich habe bereits
seine entwickelt du bist also nur unter
vorbehalt beeindruckt nein ich habe
keine vorbehalte gegen sie nur wird für
den tuning test die maschine vor den
fragen schneller verborgenen eine andere
weise hinaus würde ich sie verbergen so
dass du nur ihre stimme hört ging er als
mensch durch der wahre test ist ob du in
dem wissen dass ihren roboter ist
trotzdem empfinde ich das ihren
bewusstsein hat genau also für alle die
den film es trotzdem nicht gesehen haben
es geht damit anfangen los in das camp
eingeladen wird in das ganz inoffizielle
headquarter von dem chef von quasi
google mehr oder weniger wirklich damit
versucht zu sagen dass das ist blue book
heißt das in dem film und der superreich
und mega intelligent und er arbeitet an
künstliche intelligenz und er fragt
kelle weißt du was der tür im test ist
und das ist so ein bisschen ich glaube
jeder programmierer auf der ganzen welt
weiß was der turing test ist war es ein
bisschen sehr filmisch nach dem motto ja
dann ich weiß es natürlich auch beide
wissen aber sie müssen es natürlich auch
für den zuschauer erklären er trinkt ist
natürlich eine messlatte für
sprachsysteme die auch immer bestehen
bleiben wird und wo immer jemand den
ehrgeiz haben wird die zu knacken aber
heißen es geht es darum einfach die
forschung voranzubringen systeme zu
versorgen die effizient mit den menschen
kommunizieren können gerade die großen
tech firmen interessiert sich natürlich
dafür dass siri alexa co laufen dass sie
mit den menschen kommunizieren und nicht
dass sie den menschen vermitteln dass
ein mensch im kästchen drin sitzt
und wie weit sind wir da wurde der
touring test schon bestanden da wird man
immer mal wieder claims und dann gibt es
da wieder kritik daran es gibt auf jeden
fall kein programm das team besteht so
dass ich alle leute darüber eigentlich
sind das eher bestanden wurde gibt immer
mehr leute die meinen sie knacken das
aber meisten testet man auch nicht mit
einer person sondern man läßt 100
menschen kommunizieren und dann
vergleicht man ja immer noch mit einem
menschen dann guckt man 30 prozent hat
jetzt die maschine für menschen und da
muss auch gucken ob mehr als 30 prozent
der menschen für den menschen halten und
das macht man auch nicht nur mit sprache
sondern es gibt zum beispiel
algorithmen die texte erzeugen
rezensionen zusammenfassungen oder auch
bilder kunst und da legt man dieses
hampelt eben echte menschen vorerst
unterscheiden was ist jetzt echt was ist
künstlich das in form von text der film
macht jetzt mal was ganz anderes der
sagt ja gar nicht sagt mir bitte ob das
eis oder nicht sondern der erfinder sagt
das hier ist eine ki und der zeigt ihm
sogar das ist ein roboter und es geht
darum kannst du ja sagen ob sie
bewusstsein hat oder nicht also nochmal
ganz anderes wer aber auch da muss man
immer sehr vorsichtig sein weil der
touring cars wird damit bewusstsein
gleichgesetzt aber es ist ja nicht
bewusst seien der touring das testet nur
ob jemand so kommunizieren kann wie ein
mensch und ob das mit einem bewusster
handeln her geht oder nicht ist eine
ganz andere frage das heißt das ist gar
kein schönes ortsschild gemacht doch das
ist ein trick ist oder ein erweiterter
turing test bei dem der mensch sogar
weiß dass er mit einer maschine
integriert aber der touring test kann
nicht bestimmen ob jemand bewusstsein
hat ist sie von dir programmiert worden
mit mir zu flirten würdest du das als
betrug betrachten du nicht wer der
trainer ist dann trotzdem noch bestanden
wenn ich jetzt sagen würde ich wir haben
jetzt irgendein training testen der der
dekade ich versuche zu erkennen lenkt
mich ab ja und schummelt quasi ihn wäre
das dann trotzdem noch gestanden wenn
sie quasi das bewusst gemacht hat es
würde sehr menschliche eigenschaft zu
schonen soll der den menschen blieben
und im echten touring fest ist natürlich
auch so dass man
mit zwei wesen kommuniziert ein computer
einmal den mensch und der vielleicht
schon mit der mensch vielleicht schon
mit nur der computer das ist dann
natürlich auch am ende das urteil des
testen was irgendwie menschlich war
durch eine konversation zu testen ist im
grunde ein geschlossener kreislauf
verschlossener kreislauf was würdest du
einen schachcomputer testen an denen du
mit ihnen nur schachspiels testet man
sonst in schach computer
das kommt drauf an ich meine man kann
man kann gegen ihn spielen und zu sehen
auf ein guter züge macht aber
aber das sagt einer nicht ob er weiß
dass er schachspiel und das sagt einem
noch nicht ob er weiß was sache ist das
heißt simulation contra wirklichkeit
ehrlich gesagt überrascht mich dass ich
meine haben wir überhaupt dass das
problem in den griff gekriegt
naja wie erkenne ich ob eine maschine
eine wahre emotionen ausdrücken oder
bloß eine simulierte
über dich also wirklich oder nicht
allerdings wenn ich so darüber nachdenke
sehe ich eine dritte option
die frage die sich dann stellt ist nicht
ob sie imstande ist sich zu mögen
die frage ist ob sie nur so tut warum
sollte sie das machen keine ahnung
vielleicht weil sie denkt sie könnte mit
einer unterstützung ab haben weiß er was
leben ist weiß sie was sie macht wenn
sie lächelt hat sie wirklich emotionen
hat sie empathie das sind glaube ich die
fragestellungen mit denen um den um die
es hier geht ja einmal das gehört die
frage nach emotionen und gefühlen die
subjektive wahrnehmung sind und deswegen
auch immer mit einem bewusstsein
eigentlich verknüpft sind es gibt in dem
film auch die stelle wo er sagt sie kann
nur so mit mir interagieren und
reagieren wenn sie ein bewusstsein hat
ich glaube das falsch sie kann auch so
wie kann das auch hecken
ziel funktion und kann sich so agieren
dass sie die erreicht und
dementsprechend dinge sagen kann ja
sogar sein schlechtes empathie sogar so
war es auf einem ganz anderen level
menschen also ob das wirklich so ist
dass ein so komplexer roboter das
wirklich nur simuliert das natürlich
weil wissen wir ob dieser roboter im
bewusstsein hat nein es ist einfach ein
subjektives phänomen wir wissen beim
menschen nicht wo das bewusstsein
herkommt und ich glaube so lange wir das
nicht verstanden haben können wir auch
nicht darüber urteilen auf ein anderes
wesen bewusstsein spürt und das macht es
sehr sehr schwer über gefühle und
emotionen zu reden in dem zusammenhang
und die andere frage die hier so ein
bisschen reinkommt gerade auch mit den
schach beispiel ist versteht der
computer konzeptionell was passiert
versteht er dass schach und ein
gesellschaftsspiel ist oder versteht
aber dass sie irgendwie mit einem
menschen redet und dieser mensch gefühle
hat und was hier gerade passiert oder
gibt es nur algorithmen die auf eine
funktion hin optimieren
und das geht so ein bisschen den bereich
rein das
künstliche intelligenz oder algorithmen
oft
assoziationen lernen also eigentlich nur
korrelation
aber wenn wir darüber hinaus gehen
wollen da muss man irgendwie in causales
verständnis von mechanismen entwickeln
um irgendwie zu verstehen was ist jetzt
ein schachspiel und probiert haben also
da wird daran gearbeitet das steckt noch
in den kinderschuhen aber das glaube ich
richtungen die man gehen muss das gute
beispiel was die männer mal zu erzählt
hast ist die bilderkennung software die
bilder von kühen ganz toll erkennen kann
man zeigt man diesen algorithmus einmal
ein bild von akku die am strand steht
und schon weiß es nicht mehr was es ist
denn der der algorithmus hat sehr viel
gelernt dass kühe fast immer auf grünen
wiesen stehen und das können wir
abstrahieren wir menschen wir können
verstehen können das konzept auch von
der farbe trennen gewissen ist eine lila
kuh trotzdem ne kuh ist aber das würde
so ein algorithmus der quasi wirklich
nur 1000 bilder von kühen und 998 davon
sind auf grünen wiesen dann wird er
nicht wissen was mein kurs dann würde
das immer mit grüner wiese verbinden
und gerade das zu entkoppeln dem
computer bringen was wirklich die kuh
ist und was ist der hintergrund und was
vielleicht die belichtung jahreszeit die
flecken farbe diese unabhängigen sachen
zu lernen oder sogar die zusammenhänge
zwischen diesen unabhängigen faktoren
das ist ein sehr aktives forschungsfeld
an dem wir sogar in tübingen habe könnte
man also den roboter die das das
maschinelle heute so herstellen wie sie
sich bewegt wie sie geht wie sie ihre
balance hält dass sie auf zwei beinen
unterwegs ist und auch nur so groß ist
wie normaler mensch ja so weit sind wir
noch nicht also laufen ist eher
schwierig wird man immer gesagt ein
computer intelligenter spielen kann weil
sie sagt mein computer ist endlich
wieder fußball spielen kann also mit
rädern oder auch mit vierbeinern kriegt
man schon einiges gemacht aber laufen
gleichgewicht und irgendwie auch so ein
dynamisches agieren das ist sehr
schwierig also viel in der robotik
basiert auf kontroll theorie ich weiß
genau die abmessung von meinem körper
und ich kann berechnen was ich machen
muss was zu machen der mensch und auch
ansätze der der lernenden robotik die
lernen über so ganze reform and learning
also selbst verstärken das lernen also
das heißt ich mache erst mal zufällig
aktionen und habe ein ziel funktionen
die mir sagt ich möchte kugel bewegen da
war ich jetzt nah dran da war ich nicht
mehr dran das hat gut funktioniert also
und eine rückmeldung die mir zeigt wie
ich wäre nämlich effizient zu bewegen
und da ist man im moment das man zum
beispiel schafft so drei finger und wie
einzusetzen oder
anhand einzusetzen um objekt zu bewegen
aber dass man lernen könnte zu laufen
und dynamisch zu agieren davon dass man
schon noch weit entfernt und wenn du
jetzt wirklich so ein autonomes system
haben willst das nicht immer über wlan
mit einem rechenzentrum konferiert da
muss ich deine hardware noch total viel
tun weil wir einfach nicht das
rechenzentrum unseren kopf packen kann
und andersrum zb bei capo ist ja schon
groß und schweren damit kommt es gerade
merken hoch also viel effizientere
energieversorgung um so ein system
ablaufen zu lassen ich meine bei jedem
schritt wenn man versucht so was
nachzubauen muss man ja denken wow wie
geil unser menschlicher körper ist dass
wir das alles können wir erst unser
gehirn ist mit zwei watt oder sowas und
im vergleich zu dem was wir was wir
essen das wir mit 1500 2000 kilokalorien
das alles machen können was wir machen
wir brauchen halt für ganze
rechenzentrum brauchen wir kilowatt und
kilowatt ein kilowatt an strom nur zu
berechnen ob eine kuh da steht oder
nicht wird die crew vom strand auch eine
kuh ist ja aber da will ich jetzt bei
dir muss war wirklich mal ganz deutlich
sagen dass es der menschheit fasziniert
werden okay das heißt eva könnte es so
nicht geben wie sie wie sie sich bewegt
wie sie sich roboter bewegt von dem wie
sie wie sie redet er aber theoretisch
schon ja also es gibt wie gesagt noch
kein programm des touring testet formal
besteht aber generell es ist sehr weit
und die wissenschaftlichen bereich
kennen sagen auch gut denkbar dass jetzt
in diesem jahrzehnt die kommunikation
einfach auf menschen level stattfinden
wenn du wüsstest wie schwer es ist eine
deutung und reproduktion von mimik
beizubringen
weißt du wie es gelöst hat ich habe
keine ahnung wie du all das hier gemacht
hast
jedes mobiltelefon mehr oder weniger hat
ein mikrofon eine kamera und die
möglichkeit daten zu senden
ich habe also sämtliche mikrofone und
kameras eingeschaltet dies auf dem
scheiß planeten gibt und ich hab die
daten über bluetooth
und endliche ressourcen stimmlicher und
mimischer interaktion du hast sämtliche
handys auch der weg gehackt und die
hersteller haben sogar alle davon
gewusst wenn jetzt alle daten der welt
hat das könntest du dann das problem von
mimik und mikroproduktion um übrigen
mittel kennung dann lösen also mimik
erkennung das kommt schon ziemlich gut
aber
mimikry produktion ist natürlich auch
ein hardware problem ist das gesicht hat
irgendwie 50 muskeln und als contest in
der robotik so nachgebaut und
eingestellt kriegt ist glaube ich
schwierig wenn man das setup erstmal hat
helfen viele trainingsdaten natürlich
schon dann zu lernen wie man das richtig
verziehen aber ich glaube wir sind
extrem empfindlich darauf wenn es doch
nur ein bisschen komisch aus und das ist
glaube ich schon mal weiter weg wie
wichtig sind den daten tatsächlich im
alltag von der tatsächlich kann die
forschung es gibt so einen sehr
interessanten sprachprogramm dass ich
definitiv nie von ok und das ist
eigentlich auf 10 und 15 vom internet
trainiert das ist schon ziemlich große
datenmenge die bilder beschreiben es
wirklich extrem gutes programm in der
text generierung das größte neuronale
netz das programmiert wurde 100
milliarden parameter das ist schon viel
das anscheinend einem gewissen punkt ist
dann doch mehr daten mehr netze mehr
punkte hilfreicher es ist das beste in
der sprache kann man nicht fußball
spielen das ist halt ein spezielles
teilgebiet und denke im mittelenglischen
processing sind die ganz vorne dabei
eben nur das
machen was sie tut natürlich habe sich
grundlagenforschung das geht nicht
unbedingt darum jetzt ein sehr großes
netz sehr komplex zu trainieren sondern
wir uns wäre einfach probiert neue
konzepte zu entwickeln und dafür
brauchen wir nicht unbedingt daten es
gibt auch rein mathematische projekt
aber es ist natürlich immer gut wenn man
dann irgendwie auch testdaten hat und es
gibt sicherlich leute die zum beispiel
zeigen dass man synthetischen
medizinische daten erzeugen kann und wie
die nützlich sind und dafür braucht man
natürlich echte daten und da kommt man
auch nicht immer gleich dran und
generell wie ich schon sagen also daten
sind so die währung im schienenbereich
gehe
das ist ihr verstand
strukturiertes g statt der üblichen
schaltkreise brauchte ich etwas das auf
molekularer ebene gestalten und um
gestaltbar ist aber wenn erforderlich
seine form behält sie behält für
erinnerungen sie verändert wir bedanken
[Musik]
das ist deine hardware
web will ich was bedeutet
also grandios gemacht wenn wir normalen
computer haben da ist eine platine da
sind welche sachen drauf gelötet das
kann rechenoperationen ausführen und das
ermöglicht uns neuronale netze oder
maschinelles lernen und zu
implementieren
ermöglicht uns aber auch irgendwie
nervlich zu gucken oder youtube oder ein
word dokument zu schreiben ist einfache
rechenoperationen die da laufen und wir
brauchen unsere netze auszurechnen
er hingegen baut jetzt quasi das
neuronale netz direkt
und es gibt sogar sogenannte organische
in neuronale netzwerke unter gehöre zum
beispiel aber man forscht daran oder
probiert werte zu bauen wo dann die die
die knoten und die kanten die neuronalen
netz vorkommen eben nicht am tisch
matrix multiplikationen sind sondern
quasi kleine organische kabel durch die
strom fließt und synapsen die und
aktivierungs funktionen darstellen
wirklich dass da jetzt selber das heißt
die software ist schon in der hardware
und mit drin und was er da noch schafft
ist das dynamisch zu gestalten und das
denkt macht das ist unser gehirn so ist
dass sich dann neue verknüpfungen bilden
können und andere abgebaut werden das
ist natürlich natürlich ein traum wenn
wir dahin kommen wird
was wirklich anziehend auf dich du gibst
mir signale dass es so ist
welche micro extraktion mikroskopie
deine augen meiner augen fixieren meine
lippen
wie du meinen blick stand hält
[Musik]
oder auch nicht
also etwa erkennt dass caleb sich in sie
verliebt und sagt dass sie das erkennen
kann durch micro expressions ist das ein
milch oder gibt es die wirklich und
können ki oder algorithmen das erkennen
menschen ja es gibt diese mikro
explosion es gibt tatsächlich wohl auch
so trainierte lügendetektoren die
probieren die zu erkennen das ist
einfach sehr kurze emotionale ausdruck
im gesicht die sehr schwer zu
unterdrücken sind und da kann man
natürlich sowohl mit kamera und slow
motion aufnahmen als auch mal künstlich
natürlich schon was machen ich habe da
schon was zu gesehen gibt auch leute
hier in forschung und daneben probieren
eine bildauswertung diese mikro
explosionen aufzunehmen und zu deuten
das wäre theoretisch machbar zu erkennen
ob jemand verliebt ist anhand seiner
micro expression und durch einen
algorithmus ich werde ihr habt es für
alles einsetzbar ist aber dass mit dem
lügen scheint wohl ganz gut zu
funktionieren und ja klar ich glaube ich
schon vorstellen dass man so was auch
sehen kann die algorithmen natürlich
dann noch nicht immerhin 100 prozentige
treffer schoss aber das ist schon viel
dann so bildauswertung software zu
nutzen um dinge auszuwerten die wir
menschen nicht unterdrücken kann ja wenn
ich schon unangenehm das geht dann
geht's auf jeden fall in richtung muss
vielleicht nicht immer besser wird durch
mehr algorithmen durch mehr computer
durch mehr ja auf deiner seite kannst
vielleicht damit irgendwie verbrechen
aufklären ist auch gut ja ja immer zwei
seiten ok ich denke das war jetzt der
erste zeit hier auf dem kanal von mir
und gleich sprechen wir auf dem kanal
der max planck gesellschaft im zweiten
teil über die etwas ethischen fragen
also hat er tatsächlich ein bewusstsein
was sie mit der gesellschaft und wie
geht das alles weiter mit künstlicher
intelligenz in unserer zukunft
tatsächlich in der echten welt wenn euch
das anschauen wollt dann klickt jetzt
hier ansonsten immer vielen lieben dank
fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
osterbrink